foreign
[Music]
I told him I was going to interview you
today and he was showing me clips this
morning and I saw the rant you did about
your aunt the bad-mouth gym I don't even
know if you can talk about that because
I think it led to a suit she didn't sue
me oh she but she did come close to it
yeah she was dissuaded from other
members of the family she was very
unhappy about that yeah but she started
she started it and then you called her a
pedophile that is true
so if you've got a friend who has
something in their teeth you tell them
not if it's a girl so okay get this I
was at the Pro Bowl two years ago and
one of the reporters there I was kind of
going down the line you have to talk to
a certain amount of people and she
probably interviewed like six people
before she got to me and she's had a
huge like piece of spinach in her front
two teeth and I was like you were just
on air with six people and no one told
you you have a camera guy with four feet
from your face I told her out and I
started the interview I was like you
have some in your teeth I was like I
don't I would be so embarrassed if I
just said some of my teeth the entire
time and no one told me like come on I
thought we were friends and women that
shakes them to the core oh it's almost
like telling them they don't even exist
nothing hotter than a woman drinking a
martini hey that is the hottest sexy
all right he got me I was going for
cocktails
maybe when she's kissing another girl oh
I had to get woken up at 8am who woke
you Phil pound dude he pounds on the
door like oh he's serving a [__]
warrant it's [__] crazy dude it
nothing bothers me more
get up that's how he [__] does it
that's the best it's so [__] annoying
dude then I'm furious and then my mom's
yelling Chad from she's like a cat dude
she'll stand outside your door Jane
okay
come on let's go oh my God gotta get
moving shut up you're having like grade
school flashbacks dude I was having I
had a wild night yo I also I know this
is my dreams dude I have wild dreams
she's a cat she really sits outside your
door
[Laughter]
come on it just rubs the wall let's get
moving let's get moving oh dude there's
so many dumb women have so many dumb
phrases Legion of skanks you guys got
you guys got painted with this broad
brush that you weren't right like you
got you I remember the best was you were
called a Nazi yeah yeah a Jewish guy was
called a Nazi over and over over and
over and they don't accept I'm Jewish as
a reason for not being a Nazi that's the
best part they're always like and I'm
like yeah I don't I think the sign ups
wouldn't go well for me I think we're on
the other side of the fence guys
even if I wanted to join they'd be like
does this saying you're Jewish yeah is
that gonna be a problem guys
is that a thing still I don't know if
I'm at Liberty to say but there's a
couple of stories of uh
famously uh maybe the audience can guess
as stagehan told me and I'm not gonna
say what city it was in they can put all
these pieces together stage and said one
of the toughest guests we've ever had
was this performer this gentleman
and he walked in and he said it's [__]
but I'll need a catwalk
and they said a catwalk I'll need a
catwalk
where
where did the catwalk go well this is a
stage and there's chairs and those are
you can't he said well I guess I'll just
leave town then and left
and decided the gigs are going to be
canceled [__] it unless they're this
person has built a catwalk and sure
enough two days later the catwalk was
built and did the person use the catwalk
the entire performance
no Bobby Lee
can I say something what I love you so I
love you now what is wrong with you I'm
I I love you I'm honestly gonna miss you
I miss I'm missing you in my I'm so sick
right now anyway um thank you and I love
you and I love you more than I think
I've ever left I love you more than
anything on the minimum should we just
say something to her right now [__]
whoa I used to have this red tractor
right like I used to have this red hard
plastic tractor this is a toy a toy we
had like an armor on top okay the farmer
used to get off and like [__] with me
like when all by myself the farmer would
get off the red tractor and like talk to
me and [__] and I used to tell my mom
and I'm like okay whatever and then you
know we used to have to burn trash like
in the yard so I took the red plastic
tractor and threw it on the fire and the
guy was screaming
whoa he couldn't get off the tractor
then
[Music]
he get down with the ship I'm watching a
documentary about the International
Space Station I'm six episodes in and
nobody's addressed burping and barfing
how do you take a [__] in space and most
importantly how does one masturbate in
space because you know those particles
the ejaculate turns into those balls of
of hardened liquid right can you imagine
the first because it's been done
it's definitely been done and it's like
you're just thinking like I'll just wipe
it up whatever you're not thinking about
it and then suddenly just a cloud of
space jizz that you can't catch drifting
under the camp can you imagine when
you're like really doing work too you're
really working you're doing some like
something that actually has real
implications and then that wad flies by
your face
and you're like Tom come who's this dude
especially if you're like there's only
two guys on there and you know it's not
you yeah because it's gonna get in the
now it would get in the equipment yeah
it gets into like yeah and what if
that's what took it down like they would
challenge right
somebody's jerked off right when they
got into zero Challenger was at takeoff
so there's no gravity that's what they
want you to think I heard Korean
Facebook's [__] confusing as [__] is
this true is Korean yeah time to tag
yourself in a photo you're like is that
me
[Laughter]
[__] Mardi Gras baby you know at one
point in my life I would have enjoyed
that joke
Leanne we have had bird on we know he's
certified garbage we do do on a little
bit of a background check on you we know
you're from rural Georgia yeah all right
um give us a little bit of that
backstory no how where how close was
your closest neighbor well I grew up on
a road called DOT road okay
they get worse hold on nobody has ever
said I grew up on a road
yeah DOT road was not paved when I was a
kid but it became paved as I grew up
okay we were related to everybody on the
whole mile and a half long road and the
end of the road was a community called
Bug scuffle
I told you I told you I brought a
[__] Baller in here
Birds bringing in [__] ringers dude
that ain't Fair what the [__] man funny
thing about Bud scuffle they were all
doctors
who so how long did the how long does
the land go back in your family well
um there's a church on the land that's
in my family and I think the sign on the
front says 1840. wow we got married in
that church we got married in that
church really it's a one room one room
white clapboard one room Church yeah her
grandfather went to school in that
church my both my grandparents went to
school in that church he wrote the
musical to the hospital
a couple of heart transplants in that
place there was a swingers Lounge at
once telling that story
breakfast for dinner they don't get
excited about that no breakfast or
dinner is dinner if this is your only
argument no it's not you better step it
up because you're this is dinner
breakfast is one of the only meals that
I will wait in line for like I'll go to
like a nice like already breakfast place
and wait in line
who's waiting in line for dinner nobody
I'm not because you don't wait in line
for dinner what are you going to a
freaking what are you nuts you wait in
line for dinner not fast food what are
you crazy how many restaurants you go to
they go it's a 45 minute wait for dinner
what are you talking about none
but he gets his own table because he
videotaped himself peeing into the soup
in the back for [__] true TV
Marissa Stephanie was a physical
therapist which is not a doctor it's not
a doctor oh it's not no and by the way
the first time cancer leg lifts are not
doctors one of the first times I hung
out with the Stefano we played
basketball this is like 15 years ago 10
years ago and a guy sprained his ankle
and DeStefano was like I'm a physical
therapist and he gave him advice he's
like I forget what he said do this and
that pressure blah blah blah and the
next day this is Sarah's roommate his
ankle had [__] blown up like it was
just massive and purple and then the guy
went to the emergency room and they were
like who told you that are you kidding
and I can't tell if Chris is just
[__] or he was [__] with him
right did you ever tell him that no I
haven't he doesn't talk to me anymore
he's very successful but we used to be
pretty much like the 1975 I'm almost
certain he's not a fan of my comedy
there you go well no I I got by the way
I got clarification from The 1975 that
they actually do like my comedy oh yeah
you said it on [__] road yeah and
they became a thing yeah yeah before
they were 1975 that was just two years
after I was born yeah yeah now they're
[__] the thing and they're like yo I
guarantee you they're [__] this is
what sucks about the 1975. [__] them you
know what they were they were they were
true to their artist Roots when they
didn't like you yeah that's who the [__]
they are yeah and then they found out
Rogan could get them over and they're
like crazy whizzy I love Chrissy chaos
you [__] [__] you should have said
I still hate you you should have doubled
down and been like [__] Krista and [__]
his sunglasses oh my God I would have
came all over them yo I think I realized
why you're always funnier than your
guests on this pod is because this mic
cuts out every like fifth word every
time
I'm talking like Ice Cube raps now
see that yeah cut out a word yo y'all do
that on purpose so people don't have
timing they're not as funny as you no
that's not what you're just so this is
what you're doing this is what you're
doing so Asian so it's good to be here
that's what you're doing just speak
normally yeah no this is yeah let me
just start oh you're cheating man
[Laughter]
now I'm not gonna be as funny as you
because every fifth word cuts out and I
gotta talk like Ice Cube
it's fine podcasting stats for March
Bert Kreischer made the most guest
appearances last month going on an
incredible 12 total podcast including
flagrant The Joe Rogan Experience Madden
Shane secret podcast good for you take
your shoes off the honest Papa's hour
are you garbage Chrissy chaos kill Tony
busting with the boys and the fighter
and the kid the most viewed episode from
last month was kale Sonic on flagrant
which is currently sitting at over 2.1
million views and round two of this
year's podcast March Madness Tournament
kicks off tonight you can go vote on
your favorite Clips right now by
clicking the podcast March Madness Link
in our bio thank you for watching this
video and be sure to subscribe to joke
world right now to stay in the comedy
Loop
thank you
[Music]